[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINO TERESHKO: Thank you all
for coming and listening to us.
My name is Tino.
I work on Google BigQuery.
And we're going to talk about
some interesting, advanced
topics--
namely, real time architectures.
Real time tends to
be fairly difficult,
but it doesn't have to be.
And so we've worked really
hard to make that as
easy as possible for you.
So we'll go into that a little
bit of detailed further on.
But first, let's hear
it from a customer
who has gone
through this journey
throughout the last four
or five years with us.
Please welcome Yuki,
who is the CTO of PLAID.
Yuki, please.
YUKI MAKINO: Thanks, Tino.
Thank you for taking
time for our session.
[INAUDIBLE],, this is my
second English presentation
in my life.
So I apologize in advance.
If you cannot understand or want
to know more about the detail
of my part, please find me and
talk to me after the session.
I'll teach you Japanese
and talk in Japanese.
I am Yuki Makino, CTO of PLAID.
I am working at PLAID.
And I'm in charge of real-time
analytics data engine for about
four years--
and since the release
of our service, KARTE.
And today, I'll show you
our architecture history
and BigQuery usage pattern
in [? PLAID. ?] PLAID
is a fast-growing
start-up company in Japan.
We provide real-time
analytics SaaS named KARTE.
KARTE has three
characteristics compared
with other data services.
It's real-time,
large-scale, and global--
and multi-tenant.
Sorry.
KARTE it's a real-time
analytics tool.
So it handles data in real time.
And it has more than 500
enterprise-scale clients.
And so the data volume we
handle is a very large.
And clients are
isolated by data set,
but we share the data
collected by KARTE to clients.
And some Japanese clients
prohibit putting data
in foreign countries.
So we distribute our data
to multiple global regions
in BigQuery.
KARTE is not only a data
visualization service, but also
an action service.
So it processes data and returns
actions within one second.
So it's really a real-time
service within one second.
It processes 65,000
events per second,
three billion events per day--
and it inserts one
petabytes of streaming data
by doing inserts per month.
And currently we store
more than two petabytes
of data in BigQuery and more
than 60 petabytes of analysis
per month.
And we contracted flat-rate
[? slots, ?] where it's 6,000
[? slots-- ?] 4,000 for
US and 2,000 for Japan.
And as you can see,
this does utilize that.
We use BigQuery very heavily.
And this is the reason why I
share our experience today.
OK?
In order to understand
our architecture easily,
I'd like to have a brief
introduction of the KARTE.
KARTE is website,
real-time custom analytics
and action service.
So we call it a Customer
Experience Platform.
It is for managing customer
experience in a website
to know, real-time,
customer state
and to do the
appropriate action, which
is suitable to each user.
I'd like to show a
more technical concept
of the system.
KARTE as a concept is
real-time, reactive system.
Firstly, an end user sends
an event to our system,
and KARTE analyzes
the current user state
based on all events the user
has sent since the first visit.
This on the current state, it
returns appropriate actions
as Reactions to the latest
events the user sent.
And, also, our clients can
see real-time user state
and configure actions in
the operation in real-time.
Our clients set actions
to segment the users.
Them the actions
for some segments
start to fire instantly.
All right?
We started to use
BigQuery about four years
ago soon after
our first release.
At that time, we inserted event
row data by streaming insert
simply.
We used BigQuery just for
log analysis at this moment.
In the next phase, we started to
use BigQuery in the production
application--
the directory-- to its show
analyzed data to our clients.
We also started to insert
analyzed user state data
in BigQuery in order
to update the user
state in the application.
This is the current
architecture.
We added new data
management functions
so that our clients can import
and export data in BigQuery
with Dataflow.
And it can also export data
to Spanner and Bigtable--
to save data in Redis and
[? since ?] [? rail. ?]
BigQuery actually set up
our data cache system,
not only for us, but along
with for our clients.
We use BigQuery in
various ways to realize
a real-time analytics service.
All right, so
today, I would like
to show five real-time
BigQuery usage patterns we
use in our production system.
The first pattern is complex
query and cache pattern.
This pattern is in front
of the client application.
This pattern can
be used when you
want to make a little
time-consuming, complex query
in a production system.
Normally, when you
want to analyze
data stored in data
lake or warehouse
through the production
application,
you put an ETL layer and
fetch data by ETL to database.
Previously, we used
another ETL database
to fetch analyzed data.
But it's complex and not
flexible and not a real-time.
When we tried to change
our access pattern,
we had to change the ETL
process and the application
call to fetch the data.
So we log it in a memory cache
layer in front of BigQuery
and access it with
SQL transparently.
If you want to change
the access pattern,
you just edit the SQL
ticket the application uses.
It's very flexible.
In our case, we use
hash body with the SQL
take this as the key
of the cache entries.
If the hash entries do not
exist in the cache table,
then it runs the query
actually in BigQuery
and creates a new cache entry.
However, in this pattern,
cache missed query
takes some time, so if
you want to shorten--
to a faster query latency--
optionally, you can create
the cache asynchronously
in the background in advance.
And then, you can
reduce the latency pulp.
This is our actual
production screen.
Actually, we use the first
pattern to show this view.
You can see real-time
data in your application.
It's quick enough, right,
for my application.
The next pattern is ETL
and Simple Query Pattern.
This pattern is
also used in front
of out client application.
When you analyze data
more interactively--
you use BigQuery--
this pattern is useful.
BigQuery is powerful, so
we store our whole log--
everything-- to BigQuery.
As data log, we're
schema-less and JSON storing.
BigQuery is fast enough even
for these kind of raw data.
But if you want to do a little
heavy task, such as passing
raw JSON, jogging, and
multiple-step aggregation,
it may take more
than 10 seconds.
If you want to analyze this
schema data more interactivity,
BigQuery ELT--
Save Query-- is suitable.
Save Query is very useful--
and fast and simple.
Save Query saves query
results as a new table.
You don't need any
additional system
to do ETL on ELT. To
see real-time data,
periodically it extracts keys
and values from raw JSON,
it calculates aggregate
values, and merges it
into the summary table.
For example, with Save Query,
it passes JSON raw data
on the aggregates values,
grouped by user ID.
And it creates a row having
segments on stats of each user.
And from the production
system, the application
runs simple queries,
such as intersection.
So query debt issue of BigQuery
or Single Query is very low.
It looks like this--
super fast.
This is implemented only by
ELT-- the BigQuery table--
simply.
This next pattern is Frequent
Update Large Row Pattern.
This pattern is used
in streaming insert
or with user data.
When you query for
the latest row data,
this pattern is useful.
If the average row size and
cardinality are not so large,
you just insert all rows.
And you query the latest row
by using the STRING_AGG()
or ROW_NUMBER().
But if the average row size
and the cardinality are large,
the cost including streaming
insert cost, storage cost,
and scan cost becomes high.
So we put in a Buffer
Queue to reduce cardinality
in front of streaming insert.
Buffer Queue stores
data to be inserted
in concrete the short term.
Let's say three minutes--
it's three minutes
since the first entry.
And if we a row having
the same key comes,
it just overrides
the entry's value.
After the three minutes
since the first entry,
the entry is inserted to
BigQuery with streaming insert.
By using this Buffer Queue, it
prevents to write unnecessarily
all the loads to BigQuery.
Buffer Queue can be
implemented by data flow
or in memory queue.
Actually, we use in
memory rescue, LSQ.
In our case, we use this pattern
for analyzed user state data.
The average raw data size
is about 200 kilobytes.
And we set buffering
time to five minutes.
It inserts 800 terabytes
per month with this pattern.
If we didn't apply this
pattern, the data size
would become 10 times more.
So by using this pattern,
we reduce the cost by 90%.
The fourth pattern is Optimize
for Low-Latency Serving
Pattern.
This pattern is used for
latency-sensitive layers.
When you want to
use data in BigQuery
in a latency-sensitive system,
you can use this pattern.
Dataflow can easily
export data in BigQuery
to a distributed data store
service, including Spanner,
Bigtable, GCS, and Redis.
In our case, we export the
data to Spanner and Bigtable
to use in the
latency-sensitive layer.
For example, we export such
as membership information,
recommending information--
stored in BigQuery-- to
graph the user's state
or make recommendation actions.
Spanner and Bigtable are
key-body based data store.
So if a scope of entries
to be fetched it is small,
the latency becomes very low.
So if we want to use data
in a low-latency system,
it is reasonable to export
data to these key-body based
data store.
The last pattern is the
Direct Join Pattern.
This pattern uses the Client
Data Management layer.
If your customer has some
real-time data in BigQuery,
you can directory join it to
your data set over a project.
If your data is real-time
and the customer's data
is real-time, then JOINing
the data is also real-time.
You can't control access
rights in data sets, however.
So you should separate the
data by each customer to share.
Once the data sets
are shared, then you
can share the data set
within SQL directly.
You don't need any operation
cost for import and export.
If you use a BigQuery flat
rate, zero additional cost
is required where is data
linkage and analysis.
If you care about
sensitive data,
VPC service control helps you.
It can control access rights
of the data in GCP services
at a fine-grained level.
Direct Join Pattern can do
if the targeted data sets
are located in the same region.
In our case, on the other hand,
some BigQuery Tokyo-region
users--
including government,
financial services,
and banking services--
is restricted
to store data in Japan
by the company policy.
And they can never
export sensitive data
to foreign countries.
In this case, we copy
data from a global region
to a restricted region or
insert with streaming insert
to the restricted
region in advance.
We contract the US region and
Tokyo region at flat rate.
We analyze data in the
US region basically.
And when we want to
analyze sensitive data,
we analyze in Tokyo region.
OK, I just shared our
five real-time patterns
we use in production systems.
This is the last
slide in my part.
BigQuery is the core of
our analytics architecture
as I showed.
And it is not only large-scale
and high-throughput data
engine.
But also, it can play
an important role
in a real-time system.
And it is suitable for
global-scale service
like KARTE.
Now it is the center of
the data ecosystem for us
and also our customers.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TINO TERESHKO: Thank you, Yuki.
Thanks for team PLAID coming
out-- all the way from Tokyo--
to share their story
and share what they've
done over the past years.
But PLAID started out
with Google and BigQuery
four years ago.
And they didn't start
with-- as you saw--
the massive architecture
that they have today.
They started slow.
And that's really the message
that I want to tell you guys.
It's that you don't
have to re-platform.
You don't have to
re-architect things.
Real-time doesn't
have to be hard.
You can start with a
very basic architecture.
If you're building a
brand new architecture,
it doesn't have to be difficult.
And if you have an existing
environment, you
can simply just put
this on top of that-- so
very minimal disruption
of your existing environment.
And this is actually probably
a top-three architecture
for real-time
analytics at Google.
That's it.
Right?
Going from your application,
using BigQuery's streaming
API-- which is awesome--
straight into the query.
And your data is
available in real-time.
And a lot of our
customers do just that.
And that's perfectly acceptable.
But our services
work together well.
And everything's extendable.
So you can continue to
expand if you wish to do so.
So for example, if you have
IoT use cases, or mobile--
maybe you have gaming, logs,
and so on and so forth--
maybe it makes sense
for you to keep
some intermediate state
that passes information back
to the end device.
In which case, you
might want to use
a high-performance,
low-latency database
like Bigtable or Firestore.
We actually built integration
with both of those.
You can actually query Bigtable
data directly from BigQuery.
But that would mean
moving it into the cloud.
And on top of that, as
you saw width PLAID,
you can start using BigQuery
as an ETL or ELT tool itself.
You can move data from
left to right, cleanse it,
enrich it in BigQuery itself.
The next stage, potentially,
if you so desire
is to start thinking about a
true real-time architecture.
So you can start thinking
about putting a Cloud Pub/Sub
or Confluent Kafka
in your architecture
as the shock absorber.
And then, you can use
our excellent service--
Google Cloud Dataflow-- or
you can use Hadoop or Spark
or Spark specifically on
Dataproc for real-time data
processing.
To enrich data, to cleanse it,
to create reports in real-time.
Moving that data into BigQuery
using a streaming API again
and potentially even
cleansing it further.
So things are getting
more interesting.
And as you develop, there's
more and more options.
You can take your data
from left to right.
And finally if you
start to really want
a productize your
architecture, we
have services that allow you to
control your security, privacy,
access controls, network,
and so on and so forth--
and including orchestration.
So all of these things are
fairly flexible, right?
But let's talk about one
specific pattern here.
And that is once your data
is in BigQuery storage,
what can you do with it?
Especially what
can you do with it
that doesn't have to do with the
things that BigQuery provides?
So we've built standard
SQL with lots and lots
of extensions that allow you
to express your logic just
in plain SQL.
We've built UDFs-- user defined
functions-- that allow you
to go a little bit beyond that.
We also introduced declarative
BigQuery Machine Learning
in SQL and the geospatial
capability in the last year.
And so, all these
things allow you
to do a lot of things
on BigQuery storage--
but as long as you are bound
by these processing terms.
But of course,
you're going to say,
Tino, I have lots
of other things
I want to do with my
data, but it's already
in BigQuery storage.
What are my options?
So whether you're
using languages
like Python, Java,
or Go, maybe you
have a Jupyter
notebook or a Zeppelin.
Maybe you're using different
libraries like Pandas or Keras
or different
distributor processing
frameworks like Spark or Flink.
What are your options?
The data is already in
your data warehouse.
What can you do with it?
Well, there's a couple of them.
One is maybe your data warehouse
allows you to put agents
into the data warehouse--
you can run third-party code
in there.
Or maybe you can read data
from storage directly--
so trickling data out.
Or maybe you can
bulk export data,
which is kind of this
uncontrollable monsoon of data.
So to recap, the options are
you can trickle data out,
just by using a list API.
You're paginating
over data, which
can be about 20 megabytes
per second in BigQuery.
So it's real-time,
but it's very slow.
It's not parallelizable.
You can bulk export, which
is decisively not real-time.
It requires a middleman
like Google Cloud Storage.
It's probably going to
take you dozens of minutes
to hours to move lots
of data out of BigQuery.
So maybe it's not suitable for
some of the more real-time use
cases.
And finally, we're
not going to let
you have third-party
agents running in BigQuery.
It's just the security no-no.
It's just something
that we can't do.
So no good options, right?
And ultimately, when
you think about it,
your data warehouse
storage, typically,
is kind of locked out.
Your storage is locked
away behind a castle
with a huge wall and
a moat around it.
And yeah, you don't
have a lot of options.
I guess-- a quick segue--
I was going to use a real
image for this slide,
but I couldn't get rights to it.
So I went on Twitter last week,
and I asked folks [? thorata ?]
to draw a picture.
And this is the
winner of the contest.
And the good news
for me is that this
happens to be my boss's wife.
So it's good.
Hopefully I get a
promotion out of it.
But there is one workaround that
we see in the wild out there.
If you have data in
your BigQuery storage,
or other data warehouses,
you could potentially
keep a copy of that data--
quote unquote data lake storage.
It could be GCS.
It could be HDFS.
You could use Parquet
files or ORG files.
But this is a little complex.
It allows you to leverage these
non-BigQuery processing systems
on top of your storage.
But it's twice the
complexity, twice the cost,
twice the operational headache.
We feel like we can do better.
So I'm going to pose
the question as what
if you could treat your data
warehouse storage like a data
lake-- like storage really?
What would that look like?
Well, I have an answer for you.
And we launched something
called the BigQuery Storage API.
This solves this exact problem.
Let's talk about that some more.
So BigQuery Storage essentially
allows you to read data--
BigQuery Storage API
allows you to read data
from BigQuery Storage
at low-latency.
So one second to first byte.
It's highly parallelizable,
so if you have
something that's reading from--
that's distributed from--
BigQuery Storage API, you
will have some really serious
throughput.
We measured multiple dozens
of gigabits per second.
And it's also very flexible.
So you can take advantage of
BigQuery's columnar formats
and so on and so forth.
So it's really useful.
And it allows you to do that
non-BigQuery compute native
processing on top
of BigQuery Storage.
And with that, I'd
like to welcome
Seth, who is a Developer
Advocate Engineer.
He's going to talk a
little bit more about this
and give us a demo as well.
Seth.
SETH HOLLYMAN: Thank you, Tino.
TINO TERESHKO: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH HOLLYMAN: Thanks, Tino.
So those of you coming
from other data warehouse
technologies, when you're
dealing with your data
warehouse storage,
you're dealing
with a lot of complexity.
You have to deal with
file system layouts,
how you map storage to
nodes, all sorts of indexing
and vacuum strategies.
There's all this
management overhead
that goes with maintaining
your data warehouse.
And when we built BigQuery, we
thought maybe the thing to do
is to provide an
expert to every user.
And we do that by managing
your storage on your behalf.
You don't have to worry about
all these low-level issues
and you can focus on deriving
insights from your data
as quickly as possible.
So let's talk about
what it actually
means to be BigQuery Storage.
Our primary abstraction
is the notion of a table.
And when we present
a table to you,
we focus your
interest on the things
that matter for your use cases.
You define schemas.
So you tell us what
kind of columns
are available in
your table-- what
kind of typing information.
And we have a lot of
type functionality.
So you can do things
as simple as strings,
fixed-precision numbers,
floating point, bytes,
geography types.
We also support
complex data types
like structures and arrays.
You also provide
information that's
useful for the consumers
of your tables.
You provide descriptive
metadata about the tables
themselves-- any
information you want
to relay to users of the
tables about what's actually
contained in these columns?
How should I use this data?
There's access control policies,
data lifecycle policies.
So you can decide when should
data age out of this table?
Am I setting up for a world
where I retain all information
indefinitely?
Or do I want to maintain a
sliding 90-day, 365-day window
that tells me-- as data
ages out, remove it
from the table automatically.
I don't think about it.
The final thing you do is
you provide hints to us--
through the notion of
partitioning and clustering--
that basically tell us these
are the kinds of access patterns
I'm going to use with this data.
And we use that information
to speed up access for you.
When we look at a table, we
see a much different view.
So we take everything
from that first slide.
And that's basically
the user metadata.
And then we're doing
all the tracking
for everything else that
happens in the system.
So BigQuery supports what's
known as a snapshot isolation
model.
So at a given point
of time, we know
what data is available on
the table and what's not.
And so we maintain
all the information
about this data
arrival, data leaving.
We also have to deal with all
the replication on your behalf.
So you don't ever have to
think about where's my data?
Is it fully replicated?
That's all handled for you.
As I said earlier, the lifecycle
information-- so we know,
at a granular
level, what storage
should be arriving
and leaving the table.
Internally, we also have
a bunch of other stats
for understanding operations
that mutate storage.
So in addition to
that metadata layer,
where do we actually put
the contents of your table?
Where is the data for
your table itself held?
We've talked about this in
some blog posts previously.
So we use a columnar format for
your data, called Capacitor.
And what that does is it
provides us very fast ways
to access your data, such that
it supports analytic workloads.
So as opposed to a
transactional system,
where you're doing a lot
of frequent mutations
for individual entities, in
an analytic data warehouse,
you're scanning a lot of
rows at any given time.
We also, as this diagram shows,
in addition to grouping data
based on transactional
operations,
we also group on a higher-level
abstraction of the partitioning
information.
And so what that
effectively means
is whenever we want
to read a table,
we end up with a set
of columnar files
that we need to operate on.
Our query engine basically opens
all these up simultaneously.
And so what we've done is
we've tried to figure out a way
so that you can do
very similar things.
Essentially, what
we want to present
is the ability for you
to act as a query engine.
So on the left-- as you see--
you've selected a
table or partition,
and you want to read that into
your external application.
We deliver that through
a set of streams.
And then we do decoding
on the client side.
So, in comparison, let's talk
about what you could do today.
As Tino mentioned, we have
the table data list mechanism,
which is a paginated
cursor method.
So it's a REST API,
which means you're
doing an individual, discrete,
HTTP requests and responses
for each page of data.
You have all this op
flow to get through.
And the data is presented
to you in a JSON format.
So it's not particularly
efficient at scale.
By contrast the Storage API does
a couple of different things
to handle this.
On the network layer, we use
gRPC, a streaming RPC protocol,
to ensure that the latency for
just moving data back and forth
is as low as possible.
And we use a lot of flow
control to make sure
that data is
continuously arriving.
We use a binary
serialization format.
So those of you that are
familiar with formats
like Apache Avro,
you will be reading
Avro out of these streams.
We're also looking at
other delivery formats.
So feel free to catch
me after the talk
and tell me your
favorite format and why.
We can look at what
we want to do there.
We also use this
abstract concept
of a stream to deliver data.
And that's our unit
of parallelism.
So streams make it easy to build
consumer applications based
on the notion of
your architecture
rather than our architecture.
We didn't want to ship
a bunch of complexity
around understanding our
low-level storage interfaces,
so we built this
abstraction for you.
So when you set up a
session, you basically
tell us basic information
about what kind of data
you want to read,
properties of the table,
how you want to access it, and--
importantly-- the parallelism
you want to read it at.
Even a single stream
is generally more
performant than the
new method, simply due
to the technology changes.
As you are able to scale
up, across multiple nodes,
you can establish
additional streams.
And your throughput
goes up as well.
And you can keep doing this.
The basic bounds you have
are how much bandwidth
you have available?
Do you have the compute
capacity to do the decoding?
And what is the
underlying parallelism
of the table you're accessing?
So a very small table
may only be represented
by a single file, so you're
not able to use more than a
single stream to access it.
By contrast, as
Yuki mentioned, they
may have terabytes
to petabytes of data.
That could be represented
by hundreds or thousands
of columnar files.
And so your parallelism
factor scales
as the amount of data scales.
So the other thing
to keep in mind
is we don't make you
reason about which files
are going into which streams.
We do a dynamic dispatch.
So that, essentially, all
you have to worry about
is the stream.
And we will make sure that data
is delivered to the streams.
And we allocate
things in a safe way,
so you don't have to
worry about duplication
due to the network transport.
However, you're dealing
with distributed systems.
Distributed systems fail.
They just do.
So how do you deal with that
when accessing your storage
through this API?
So we essentially present three
levels of recovery and error
control.
So each of those streams
has an offset mechanism.
So if you have a bad
read, you can basically
restart at the last
point you had a good read
and continue on.
For example, here if your
receiving node failed,
and you needed to restart
the entire stream,
that's perfectly
legitimate as well.
And say you had a much
more catastrophic failure--
you can restart
the entire stream.
And we will deliver the
data in the same order
we did in the original session.
One thing to keep
in mind, though--
many applications are
inherently single node.
A lot of people have tools that
just run on a local machine.
As long as you have sufficient
capacity on that machine,
it's perfectly OK to
fan in multiple streams
onto that worker.
One thing to keep in mind--
there is no ordering guarantees
for each element of the stream.
So you can't say
stream one is going
to get A through M, et cetera.
So when we think
about the Storage API,
we want to give you
the same capabilities
we give our query engine, which
means projection and filtering.
If you only want two
or three columns--
out of a very wide schema--
we will only deliver
those columns.
That speeds you up, because
obviously, we're not
sending that over the network.
And we're able to leverage
our columnar format.
So it's very fast
for us to do this.
Similarly, you can establish
processes row filters
to say, I would
like to throw away
any data on the
server-side before it even
comes across the network,
so that my consuming
application doesn't
have to even look at it.
And you can do that as well.
So as I mentioned, we have a
snapshot isolation mechanism.
This is sometimes called
time travel in our system.
So we also give you
the ability to say,
I would like to read this
table as of midnight yesterday,
or three hours ago.
Cases where you might
want to do this--
if you just recently
did a big, DML update
and changed a bunch
of your data and went,
wait what was the state of
that table before I did that?
You can walk before that event.
Similarly, if you're
doing simultaneous reads
of a bunch of tables and you
want a coherent point in time
for all three of them, or
however many you're reading,
you can set the snapshot
time for all of them
to be identical.
So if I could switch
to the demo real quick.
So one thing to keep in mind is
I'm terrible at visual demos.
So what we'll be
doing today is I'm
going to demonstrate comparing
the use of the existing
API to the new API.
And we're going to use some data
from the public data program--
the public data sets program.
And in this case, what we're
going to be working with
is something called the
sample_commits table.
So it's basically a subset
of all the commit history
in GitHub open source projects,
restricted to some subset
of the available projects.
And we do that because the
raw data is 753 gigabytes.
And we can demo it.
But it will be a much
longer demo session.
This one, by contrast, is
only about 2 and 1/2 gigs--
a couple hundred thousand rows.
And so let's look at--
essentially, I have
three nodes here--
GCE VMs, absolutely
vanilla, that I've just
put a variant of Debian on.
So, to set the
stage, the top box
is the existing cursor method.
It's going to move,
but it's not going
to move particularly fast.
So, if we switch to the Storage
API and a single stream,
we're doing a little better.
We're certainly going
to arrive at the end
before the first one.
So let me stop that.
And let's parallelize
it some more.
So my beautiful bar chart--
each color is the data being
delivered to a specific stream.
So with a parallelism
factor of 4,
we're moving a little faster.
We can stop that,
make it bigger--
add more streams.
Unfortunately, text demos
aren't the greatest for visuals,
but low-level storage
APIs don't inherently
make for great visual demos.
I'm sorry.
So let's do one more thing.
So in addition to that,
we talked about the fact
that you can do
column projections.
So if we say, we're
only interested
in the actual commit hash and
the author's email address--
the addresses are anonymized.
So we lose the identifier,
but we keep the domain suffix
in this data set.
A little faster.
And the last thing
we can do is say--
So this bar chart
doesn't look very pretty,
because we're filtering
almost all the data out.
As you can see, we
apparently-- this
is the equivalent
of a count star
query on the table where we
say where the domain suffix is
like that filter.
So we have-- apparently--
6,000 commits in
the GitHub data.
And as you can see, we're
still waiting on tabledata
to make its way to
the end of the table.
That's all I had for
the demo, could we
switch back to the screen?
Now I'd like to--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Tino, I'll turn it
back over to you.
And--
TINO TERESHKO: Yes, sir.
SETH HOLLYMAN: --I'll
go sit down over here.
TINO TERESHKO: Yes.
Wow.
Fantastic.
Thank you so much, Seth.
So yes, I think between hand
drawings of castles and text
demos, we've really
raised the bar here.
But the point stands--
it's a really, really fast API.
And as a product manager,
I like this slide a lot.
And hopefully as a customer--
as a user of BigQuery Storage
API--
you'll like it as well.
So it's in beta.
It's out now.
Go start using it.
There are still some things that
we want to do to get it to GA.
But it's already out there.
It's already highly useful.
So how do you use it?
Well, one is if you
have Dataproc running--
or Hadoop or Spark--
we have released
and are continuing
to release a number of
connectors-- so for example
Hive, MapReduce, Spark
SQL, or you can actually
even just create a
Pandas data frame that
is powered by BigQuery Storage.
This is really
powerful because--
for one-- the patterns
I've described before,
you no longer have to do that.
And two is you don't
need to sample your data
and reduce it all
on Ubiquity storage
before loading into Pandas.
You simply have a
data frame that runs
on top of BigQuery Storage.
The next one is if
you're using Dataflow--
which is an incredibly powerful,
unified batch and stream
processing engine--
you can read data out
of BigQuery Storage.
Do some enrichment from
third-party sources--
maybe Pub/Sub--
and put it back into
BigQuery Storage using
our real-time streaming API.
So now you have a real-time
ETL processing system.
So the Dataflow
connector is out there.
You can start using it today.
Finally ODBC and JDBC--
those are some good
examples of tools
that could be potentially
be benefiting from this.
We've already updated
the JDBC driver,
and ODBC is coming very shortly.
You just get a quantum
leap of performance
if you're using any third-party
tool that relies on mass
or you're programmatically
connecting
BigQuery using ODBC or JDBC.
And finally it's--
as Seth pointed out--
an API.
So you can start using it.
Just go and start building
code on top of it.
We'll have client libraries
and all the good stuff
that you used to relying on.
And we'll continue to
expand on this ecosystem.
So as Seth pointed out, if
you have some requirements--
if you're interested
in other things that
could work on top of BigQuery
Storage API, please let us
know.
We're really excited
to build all that.
And so I'll kind of
give you a whirlwind
of the different patterns
that are possible here.
And you saw some of
them live with PLAID.
But this is just a sampling.
This is not everything
that we can give you.
But I'm really excited to
tell you that that one pattern
of your data being in BigQuery
Storage is now-- we feel like--
very unique and very powerful.
And we're looking
forward to hearing
how our customers using this.
We already have a couple
of users of this API--
Mixpanel and Taplytics-- which
are kind of similar to PLAID.
They're marketing
analytics providers.
And they're using this at scale.
And it has opened up a
new way of doing things.
It's much simpler
than the old ways.
It allows a cleaner
architecture of general.
[MUSIC PLAYING]